le blasphème n'est pas christophe rault
qui lui rejoint plus tôt ce qui s'est
passé sur twitter aujourd'hui christophe
vous vous êtes choqués oui je suis
choquée mais j'ai bien juste qu'on se
rappelle tous ensemble ce qui s'est
passé en 2015 évidemment cet attentat
odieux
bien sûr que tout le monde autour de ce
plateau et que tout le monde de l'autre
côté du téléviseur évidemment condamne
avec la plus grande des forces parce que
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec un
journal avec une satire on ne peut
évidemment pas accepter ce qui s'est
passé et je me souviens du sentiment
effroyable que j'ai ressenti lorsque
j'ai appris cette triste nouvelle
une fois qu'on a dit ça je me rappelle
aussi qu'il ya eu un espèce de chantage
qui nous a été imposée dans les médias
et par beaucoup de journalistes aussi le
fait de dire on n'est pas charlie ça
voulait dire que nous étions vous êtes
nous étions favorables aux attentes à ce
qui s'était passé
pas du tout moi j'aimerais un jour et en
syrie fait la malle montre je ne suis
pas charlie wi et je ne condamne pas les
attentats mais je ne suis pas charlie ça
veut pas dire que je suis pour les
attentats c'est là que cette stupidité
c'est quoi ce raccourci est évidemment
je serai jamais pour la violence parce
que pour moi la violence et le refuge
des incompétents mais j'ai le droit
aujourd'hui en toute démocratie de dire
que ce que fait ce qu'a fait charlie
hebdo ce qui avait été fait d'ailleurs
précédemment dans la presse suédoise si
je ne m'abuse avait heurté les quelques
1 milliard de musulmans
et à partir du moment où on earth une
catégorie de personnes à travers le
monde ça me dérange qu'on ne vienne pas
me dire la liberté d'expression non elle
ne permet pas tout monsieur naulleau la
liberté d'expression vous choquer
quelqu'un ou un groupe d'individus
eh bien il faut réfléchir avant de faire
ça et moi ce qui m'a choqué hier en
revoyant cette caricature au post et je
me suis dit mais quel est le niveau des
journalistes en france
j'avais envie de dire au lieu de faire
du copier coller comme ce qu'on fait
beaucoup dans la presse aujourd'hui on
est témoin il y aurait pu avoir une
espèce de créativité c'est ce qui a fait
un petit peu l'objectif d'un journaliste
c'est d'essayer de créer d'apporter de
la nouveauté est aujourd'hui de recopier
ça c'est encore une nouvelle fois de la
provocation et j'écoutais comme vous
cyril ce matin chez morandini
bruno mais aussi un interlocuteur dont
je me souviens plus son nom un monsieur
qui avait apparemment un parcours assez
brillant qui disait
attention attention parce que ce que ce
qu'a fait encore charlie hebdo
ça va nous coûter encore des morts ça va
nous coûter des policiers ça va nous
coûter des gendarmes
tu vois des gens qui sont au mali et ça
on n'a pas le droit d'échouer explique
je vois le public dans tous nos btp qui
est plutôt d'accord avec ce que dit
christophe les voit tous hocher la tête
donc voilà et qu'ils sont plutôt
d'accord avec mes dents avec les i love
sera charles il se sera charlie le
coupable on n'a pas dit ce qui est dit
vers ce paradis des contrevérités cible
alors alors alors ça exprimez-vous eric
naulleau on croirait que c'est charlie
qui commet un attentat contre les
musulmans
alors ils ont pas été agressé par les
musulmans ils ont été agressés par des
scripts des extrémismes des terroristes
qui s'en prennent indifféremment aux ans
qu'ils soient musulmans ou pas la preuve
dans les attentats contre charlie et les
autres qui avait déposé la question des
juifs etc
alizée là maintenant je dois juste qu'il
vaut mieux bien on dirait vraiment que
c'est à dire et on inverse dans les
camps inverse le procès c'est les
terroristes qu'il faut accuser celles
qui sont intolérants qui l'occupé pas
charlie qui fait chaud mais qu'est ce
que votre question je souhaiterais dans
le respect de la loi
vous posez une question si vous
permettez effectivement vous avez raison
mais aujourd'hui moi je me mets à la
place de ces musulmans qui vont la
grande globalité
on est évidemment manifesté leur
hostilité par rapport à ce qui était
passée ils ont aussi étaient dans la rue
pour dire non plus jamais ça parce que
faut rappeler aussi que parmi les
attentats les victimes des attentats en
dehors de charlie hebdo je pense au 13
novembre
il y avait beaucoup de musulmans donc
ils ont été touchés aussi dans leur
coeur moi je me mets à la place de ces
individus monsieur naulleau est ce que
ça vous gêne pas dirt et c'est ces gens
qui sont globalement pacifique et qui
veulent préserver un vivre ensemble
c'est ce que nous voulons vous et moi
monsieur nono préserver ce vivre
ensemble
mais tout ce qu'ils valent abîmé me
dérange voilà pourquoi moi j'ai eu moi
j'ai envie de heurter des gens là mais
moi je suis catholique il ya eu 50 une
de chablis roudaut nommé voilà 58 de
charrier mais alors je vais vous dire
que pour eux mais je demande
l'interdiction est ce que je vais les
agresseurs d'autres joueurs que tu sais
aussi aujourd'hui énormément de
catholiques il est une chute de charlie
hebdo
ça dérange pas je me dis que c'est
d'accepter en démocratie le dérangement
dans les limites de la loi
moi j'accepte sur le dérangement oui je
ne vais pas les agresser je ne vais pas
les insulter je ne demande pas un match
où je trouve cette une maquette ridicule
la trouvent choquante vrai je ne vais
pas demander l'interdiction de shalla
corp alors aimant